其他人： 8个
Others: 8
Shure:  那我们下一个环节
Shure: So our next segment
Shure:  啊不是 呸 啊
Shure: Ah, no, ugh, ah
Shure:  下下一下一个介绍
Shure: The next, next introduction
Shure:  5个币子开始
Shure: Start with 5 coins
Shure:  5
Shure: 5
Tasha: 就差两啊
Tasha: Just two more
Shure:  4
Shure: 4
其他人： 太廉价了
Others: Too cheap
Shure:  3 我记住了
Shure: 3, I got it
Shure:  3个啦
Shure: 3 now
Shure:  上吧上吧
Shure: Go, go
Shure:  两个
Shure: 2
Shure:  哎不让了不让了
Shure: Hey, no more, no more
Shure:  一个了啊
Shure: Down to 1
Shure:  然后后面呢
Shure: And then
Shure:  就可就没有了
Shure: That's it
Shure:  我们后面的拍品非常的精彩的
Shure: Our next items are really exciting
Shure:  我们提前看过大家的这些
Shure: We've previewed everyone's items
Shure:  这些拍品都非非常的非常的棒
Shure: These items are really, really great
Shure:  真的真的没有在自告奋勇来
Shure: Seriously, no one's volunteering?
Shure:  来介绍一下的吗
Shure: To introduce?
Shure:  那6个
Shure: Then 6
其他人： 我去一楼看看我被找钱了给自己增加一些拍卖经历
Others: I'll go check the first floor, get some change, and increase my auction experience
Shure:  你看这啥 6个
Shure: Look at this, 6
Shure:  不能再多了啊
Shure: No more
Shure:  只有6个
Shure: Only 6
Shure:  再给大家最后3秒钟考虑时间
Shure: Giving you all 3 more seconds to think
Shure:  没有
Shure: No
Shure:  我们这波就直接进行下一个环节了啊
Shure: Let's move to the next segment
Shure:   3 2 1
Shure: 3, 2, 1
Shure:  好的那我们结束introduction环节
Shure: Okay, we end the introduction segment
Jake: 我们花了整整5分钟
Jake: We spent a full 5 minutes
Shure:  可以 OK
Shure: Alright, OK
Shure:  那我们就进行呃
Shure: So let's proceed to
Shure:  guest的那个拍卖环节吧
Shure: The guest auction segment
Shure:  然后
Shure: Then
Shure:  大家看一眼自己手头的币子都有多少
Shure: Everyone check how many coins you have
Shure:  现在谁的
Shure: Now who
Shure:  要不谁的币子少谁先上来拍
Shure: Whoever has the fewest coins, goes first
Shure:  给你先赚点钱嘛
Shure: I'm helping you make some money first.
Tasha: 好 他的东西我最期待
Tasha: Alright, I'm most looking forward to his stuff.
Katrina:  是那个胶片黑白卷
Katrina: It's that black and white film roll.
Katrina:  洗出来底片是我自己去拍的
Katrina: The developed negatives are ones I took myself.
Katrina:  然后今天带了5个
Katrina: And today, I brought five of them.
Katrina: 它是基本上都是风景应该是有
Katrina: They're basically all landscapes, there should be...
Katrina: 四张大海然后有一张是楼房
Katrina: Four of the sea, and one of a building.
Katrina:  就是很神奇的是因为它是黑白卷
Katrina: What's amazing is that they're black and white rolls.
Katrina: 正常这么看看不到需要用
Katrina: Normally, you can't see anything by just looking at it, you need...
Katrina: 对需要看哪 面是正面
Katrina: Yeah, you need to see which side is the front.
Katrina:  这面是正面，需要用光照一下
Katrina: This side is the front, you need to shine some light on it.
Katrina:  能看到它那个里面的开关还蛮
Katrina: You can see the switch inside, it's pretty...
Katrina:  很有意思的
Katrina: Quite interesting.
Alice: 老公给我买一个
Alice: Honey, buy one for me.
Katrina: 就是相当于 是由我把它画出来的，是由
Katrina: Basically, I drew it out, and...
其他人：我找到了
Others: I found it!
Katrina: 随身自己带着一小片属于自己的海的感觉而且我
Katrina: Carrying a small piece of the sea with me, and...
Tasha: 我们4个
Tasha: The four of us...
Tasha: 买两个吗
Tasha: Buying two, right?
Katrina: 可以去就是通过对着手机的手电或者对着阳光才能看到
Katrina: You can see it by shining your phone's flashlight or sunlight on it.
Katrina:  蛮有意思的反正我觉得挺有意思的
Katrina: It's pretty interesting, I think it's quite interesting.
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And then...
Tasha: 我出你就别出
Tasha: If I bid, you don't bid.
Tasha: 你出我就别出
Tasha: If you bid, I won't bid.
Shure:  肖老师觉得这个每张呢就
Shure: Mr. Xiao thinks that each of these...
Shure:  一个起拍先
Shure: Let's start the bidding with one.
Shure:  OK那就先一个起拍
Shure: Okay, let's start the bidding with one.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright?
Shure:  总共有5个
Shure: We have a total of five.
Shure:  那么第一张
Shure: So, the first one...
其他人：第一张是什么啊
Others: What's the first one?
Shure:  第一张射手
Shure: The first one is Sagittarius.
其他人：拿手电照 一下
Others: Shine a flashlight on it.
Shure:  第一张是哪个
Shure: Which one is the first?
Shure:  是有一块
Shure: There's a piece...
其他人：哦对
Others: Oh, right.
其他人：这5张其实不是同一个地方
Others: These five are actually from different places.
其他人：应该就是山东沿海那几个城市都呆过
Others: They should be from several coastal cities in Shandong.
Tasha: 我不是给你4个了吗
Tasha: Didn't I give you four?
其他人：然后大概是从20年 到现在都是疫情之后拍的海
Others: And roughly from 2020 to now, taken after the pandemic.
Tasha: 你还呀
Tasha: You still want it?
Tasha: 这是我们俩共同资产
Tasha: This is our shared asset.
Shure:  这张是一个有着很多礁石的一个海
Shure: This picture is of a sea with many reefs.
Shure:  然后起拍价一
Shure: The starting bid is one.
Shure:  一个 两个
Shure: One, two.
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Twice for two.
Shure:  两个两次
Shure:  好我这边出3个
Shure: Alright, I bid three.
Shure:  3个一次
Shure: Once for three.
Shure:  三个两次啊
Shure: Twice for three.
Shure:  还有没有想要的
Shure: Anyone else want it?
Shure:  这个这个
Shure: This, this.
Shure:  非非常的beautiful
Shure: It's very beautiful.
Shure:  这个我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure:  这是这五个里面比较不错的一个
Shure: This is one of the best among these five.
Tasha: 我天他对自己女朋友的拍品
Tasha: Oh my, he highly praises his girlfriend's auction item.
Tasha: 大加赞赏
Tasha: High praise indeed.
Tasha: 非常停留了非常的时间
Tasha: It's been quite a long time.
Shure:  三个次那就自产自销一下了
Shure: Three times, let's sell it ourselves.
Shure:  好了
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  我我我收下了啊
Shure: I'll take it.
Shure:  怎么回啊
Shure: How do I reply?
Shure:  我真想要
Shure: I really want it.
Shure:  啊不一样
Shure: Ah, it's different.
Shure:  给你发三个来
Shure: I'll send you three.
其他人：我手工品你带回去
Others: Take my handmade items back with you.
其他人： 没有没有我猜是因为他昨天跟我讲找了一下没有可以相着不会思考可是很有意思的
Shure:  好的
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  那我们下一个
Shure: Let's move on to the next one.
Shure:  这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Shure:  哦这是一个栏杆旁边的一个大汉
Shure: Oh, this is a big guy next to a railing.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  也是起拍价一
Shure: Starting bid is one.
Shure:  一个
Shure: One.
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two.
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Twice for two.
Shure:  两个两次
Shure:  三个三个一次
Shure: Three, once for three.
Shure:  三个两次
Shure: Twice for three.
Shure:  还有更高的吗
Shure: Is there anything higher?
Shure:  三个三次落锤
Shure: Three times with the hammer.
Shure:  成交哈
Shure: Sold!
其他人： 坏了 你这你这你这产生了阶级
Others: Oh no, you just created a class system.
Tasha: 我们是中产阶级
Tasha: We are the middle class.
Shure:  还有
Shure: And...
Shure:  还有一个啊
Shure: There's one more.
Shure:  第三个
Shure: The third one.
Shure:  第三个是一个 出价两个
Shure: The third one is one, starting with two.
Shure:  还有一个是楼
Shure: And there's a building.
Shure:  其他的几个都是啊
Shure: The rest are all...
Shure:  哦这是
Shure: Oh, this is...
其他人： 哦这是这张是青岛那个一派帆船中心
Others: Oh, this one is from the Qingdao Sailing Center.
Shure:  这是一个带有船的海
Shure: This one has a boat on the sea.
Shure:  还有后背景是一个
Shure: And the background is...
Shure:  不要到最后一个
Shure: Don't go for the last one.
Tasha: 不要到最后一个拍会很高
Tasha: Don't go for the last one, it will be very high.
Shure:  还有一些楼
Shure: And there are some buildings.
Shure:  起拍价一个两个
Shure: Starting price is one, two.
Shure:  一个两个
Shure: One, two.
Shure:  两个两个一次
Shure: Two, two once.
Shure:  两个两次哦
Shure: Two, two twice.
Shure:  他又三个
Shure: Now three.
Tasha: 这就是资产阶级
Tasha: This is the bourgeoisie.
Shure:  哎呦四个
Shure: Oh wow, four.
Shure:  4个一次
Shure: Four once.
Shure:  4个两次
Shure: Four twice.
Shure:  4个3次
Shure: Four three times.
Shure:  so 成交
Shure: So, sold!
其他人：他只有4个
Others: He only has four.
Shure:  然后大家拿到手可以直接用
Shure: Then everyone can use it directly.
其他人：我要增加一下我的拍卖资金
Others: I need to increase my auction funds.
Lucia: 这个如果大家一会有喜欢也可以拍拍试试
Lucia: If anyone likes it, you can try to bid for it later.
Shure:  然后下一个
Shure: Then the next one.
Lucia: 这也是压花
Lucia: This is also embossed.
Tasha: 好好那我的呢
Tasha: Okay, what about mine?
Tasha: 不管我这瓶就是我的
Tasha: Anyway, this bottle is mine.
Shure:  要不你拿着给大家展示一下
Shure: How about you hold it up and show everyone?
Shure:  呃我拿着来
Shure: Uh, I'll hold it.
Shure:  还是给大家展示一下吧
Shure: Still, show it to everyone.
Shure:  这个会看的更
Shure: This will look more...
Lucia: 哎我把手机放哪
Lucia: Hey, where did I put my phone?
Lucia: 在这
Lucia: Here it is.
Shure:  更那什么一点
Shure: More, um, something.
Shure:  对给大家看一下
Shure: Yeah, let's show everyone.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  这是一个纯的海面
Shure: This is a pure ocean view.
Shure:  然后还有啊
Shure: And then there's, um...
Shure:  还有这个
Shure: There's this.
Shure:  这个是一个楼的
Shure: This is a building view.
Shure:  还有这两个
Shure: And these two.
其他人： 都是纯景选的都是没有人的那个
Others: They are all pure scenery, no people in them.
Shure:  对纯景的
Shure: Yeah, pure scenery.
其他人：因为有人的不太好
Others: Because the ones with people aren't that good.
Shure:  那就先先拍一个楼的吧好吧
Shure: So let's start with a building view, shall we?
Shure:  这个楼的啊对
Shure: This building, yeah.
Shure:  一个大摩
Shure: A big skyscraper.
Shure:  呃也不算摩天吧
Shure: Uh, maybe not a skyscraper.
Shure:  就是楼的一个景
Shure: Just a building scene.
Shure:  起拍价还是一个
Shure: Starting bid is...
Shure:  一个
Shure: One...
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two...
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two once.
其他人：哄抬一下特价啊
Others: Raise the price a bit, special offer.
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two twice.
Tasha: 我靠这资产阶级受不了了
Tasha: Oh my god, I can't stand this bourgeoisie.
Shure:  那你怎么都要买过来是吗
Shure: So you're going to buy it, right?
Tasha: 受不了了
Tasha: I can't stand it.
Shure:  3个三个一次
Shure: Three, three once.
Tasha: 我觉得三个是顶价下次我们直接拍三个
Tasha: I think three is the top price, next time we'll start with three.
Shure:  3个两次
Shure: Three twice.
Tasha: 等有人说一个
Tasha: When someone says one.
Tasha: 我们就说三个
Tasha: We'll say three.
Tasha: 不说了断层
Tasha: No more, cut off.
Tasha: 断层就不会有人买
Tasha: If we cut off, no one will buy.
Shure:  3个三次
Shure: Three, three times.
Tasha: 不过最后一个了
Tasha: But it's the last one.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What to do?
Shure:  成交
Shure: Sold.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Shure:  还有最后一个
Shure: There's one last one.
Shure:  这个是一个海的啊
Shure: This one is from the sea.
Jake: 这怎么卖啊
Jake: How do you sell this?
Shure:  对这个是个海的
Shure: Yes, this one is from the sea.
Shure:  起拍价还是一个
Shure: The starting bid is still one.
Tasha: 不是为什么有人吃了
Tasha: Why did someone eat it?
Tasha: 给我一个
Tasha: Give me one.
Shure:  一个
Shure: One.
Jake: 对呀怎么卖啊
Jake: Yeah, how do you sell it?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: I don't know.
Shure:  有人一个
Shure: Someone bid one.
Jake: 这要卖了
Jake: We need to sell it.
其他人： 两个
Others: Two.
Jake: 给给他钱吧
Jake: Give him the money.
Shure:  两个两个一次
Shure: Two, two once.
Shure:  你就不要不要跟gas抢了好吗三个
Shure: Don't compete with gas, okay? Three.
Tasha: 三个
Tasha: Three.
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two, two twice.
Jake:他也是是乱分的是吗
Jake: Is he also randomly dividing it?
Tasha: 三个
Tasha: Three.
Shure:  三个一次
Shure: Three, once.
Jake: 试吃 一下
Jake: Taste test.
其他人：我也试吃一下回口比较好我一会儿帮你卖一下
Others: I'll taste test it too, it's good. I'll help you sell it later.
Shure:  三个三个好
Shure: Three, three, okay.
Shure:  三个一次
Shure: Three, once.
Tasha: 好你就说出你的真实体验就行
Tasha: Okay, just say your real experience.
Jake: 这大老板都是这
Jake: All the big bosses do this.
Shure:  三个两次
Shure: Three, twice.
其他人：对我已经体验过了
Others: Yes, I've already experienced it.
Shure:  没事咱们咱们可以说着
Shure: It's fine, we can talk about it.
Shure:  四个 四个一次
Shure: Four, four once.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Shure:  四个两次
Shure: Four, twice.
Shure:  四个三次
Shure: Four, three times.
Shure:  成交
Shure: Sold.
Tasha: 买不到了算了
Tasha: Can't buy it, forget it.
其他人：太急迫了马上必须 马上把钱给我
Others: Too urgent, must give me the money immediately.
Tasha: 要不是把钱要不是替你还债了
Tasha: If it weren't for paying off your debt...
Tasha: 要不是要不是替你还债了
Shure:  好的然后
Shure: Alright then...
Shure:  现在谁手上的比较少一点
Shure: Who has the least in their hands right now?
Tasha: 你有什么可拍的
Tasha: What do you have to shoot?
其他人：8+8-，对12个
Others: 8+8-, yeah, 12.
Shure:  还有12个你呢
Shure: Still 12, how about you?
其他人：还有12个
Others: Still 12.
Shure:  6个
Shure: 6.
Tasha: 我去自我介绍
Tasha: I'll go introduce myself.
Tasha: 没有用呀
Tasha: It's useless.
Shure:  那黄导你先上来介绍一下你的拍品吧
Shure: Nicous, why don't you come up and introduce your auction item?
Tasha: 4个
Tasha: 4.
Shure:  是中间这个相机吗
Shure: Is it this camera in the middle?
其他人：这玩意我看看
Others: Let me have a look at this thing.
Jake: 你要要这相机我们直接起飞
Jake: If you want this camera, we'll fly straight away.
Jake: ego币
Jake: Ego coins.
Tasha: 我一百五十个给你
Tasha: I'll give you one hundred and fifty.
Shure:  ego币直接起飞
Shure: Ego coins, straight away.
Shure:  来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure:  黄导黄导先上
Shure: Nicous, you go first.
其他人： 不幸的问题是我今天还真没有什么拍品
Others: Unfortunately, I really don't have any auction items today.
其他人： LUCIA 好像完全忘记跟我说这个事儿
Others: Lucia seems to have completely forgotten to tell me about it.
Lucia: 我好像没跟他说这个事
Lucia: I think I forgot to tell him.
Alice: 讲个故事
Alice: Tell a story.
Alice: 哎不对这是拍卖会
Alice: Oh no, this is an auction.
Lucia: 因为我自己也忘了
Lucia: Because I forgot too.
Jake: 表演一下没关系的
Jake: Perform something, it's fine.
其他人：拍卖一下才艺
Others: Auction a talent.
Shure:  还可以
Shure: That works.
Lucia: 你不是还有一瓶水吗
Lucia: Don't you still have a bottle of water?
Shure:  拍卖
Shure: Auction it.
Alice:卖艺啊
Alice: Sell your talent.
Jake: 哎好可以
Jake: Oh, that works.
Lucia: 你不是还有一瓶水吗
Lucia: Don't you still have a bottle of water?
其他人：哦非常实用啊 实用道具
Others: Oh, very practical, a practical prop.
Jake: 完了和和市场接轨了现在
Jake: Now we've really aligned with the market.
Shure:  他这有一瓶我们这都没有的饮料
Shure: He has a drink that none of us have.
其他人： 市场化道具
Others: A marketable prop.
Shure:  起拍价一个
Shure: Starting bid is one.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  那个
Shure: That.
Jake: 你后面的是不是
Jake: Is it the one behind you?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn it.
Shure:  要不这样吧
Shure: How about this?
Shure:  那个给大家一起我们拍一组照片
Shure: How about we take a group photo together?
Shure:  然后
Shure: Then...
Lucia: 啊这个太擅长
Lucia: Oh, I'm really good at this.
Shure:  这个他擅长
Shure: He's good at this.
Shure:  也算是卖了一波艺
Shure: It's like showing off our skills.
Shure:  怎么怎么拍
Shure: How should we pose?
Shure:  你可以定时下或者是怎么着
Shure: You can use a timer or something.
其他人：拍到了给他们拍一组写真
Others: Take a set of portraits for them.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake: 灯灯灭了
Jake: The light's out.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 可能是吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake: 看一下吧
Jake: Let's check.
Jake: 没有就算了
Jake: If not, then forget it.
Jake: 看一下看一下
Jake: Take a look, take a look.
其他人： 后面的背景会有些黑看见光了
Others: The background might be a bit dark; there's some light.
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Oh my.
Lucia: 有点有点背光
Lucia: It's a bit backlit.
其他人： 哦逆光
Others: Oh, backlight.
其他人： 还是到我们这边来
Others: Better come over to our side.
其他人：我把饮料搁这
Others: I'll put the drink here.
Lucia: 都站到那个椅子的前面去吗还是
Lucia: Should we stand in front of the chair or...
其他人：啊你往后推就行
Others: Yeah, just push it back.
其他人： 那要不把椅子调个吧 因为前面有些坐着比较好
Others: Maybe adjust the chair since sitting in front is better.
Shure:  来来来老板C位
Shure: Come on, come on, boss in the center.
Jake: 哼
Jake: Hmph.
Jake: 老板
Jake: Boss.
Jake: 对我调不过去
Jake: I can't adjust it.
Jake: 你帮我调
Jake: Help me adjust it.
Jake: 帮我调第一个
Jake: Adjust the first one for me.
其他人： 那我们往后
Others: Let's move back.
其他人：坐着还坐到这儿
Others: Should we sit here or...
Jake: Gast先坐行吗
Jake: Can Gast sit first?
其他人： 之前都谁坐了先坐吧 还坐着
Others: Whoever sat before, sit first. Still sitting.
Shure:  Gaste先坐吧
Shure: Let Gaste sit first.
Jake: 然后就是志愿者往后坐
Jake: Then the volunteers sit back.
Jake: Gaster先往前坐
Jake: Gaster, sit in front first.
Jake: Gaster往前坐
Jake: Gaster, move forward.
Shure:  纯黑的哦
Shure: Pure black, huh?
其他人：其实只有第二排能拍到 是吧
Others: Actually, only the second row can be seen, right?
Shure:  弄个纯黑的
Shure: Make it pure black.
Jake: 哦那前面三个椅子干掉是吧
Jake: Oh, then we'll get rid of the three chairs in front, right?
Jake: 挪掉
Jake: Move them away.
Shure:  来吧老板站站站到这位
Shure: Come on, boss, stand here.
Tasha: 可以可以
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Alice: 拍照
Alice: Take a photo.
Lucia: 拍照环节
Lucia: Photo session.
Jake: 哎请坐请坐
Jake: Hey, have a seat, have a seat.
Shure:  本来最高
Shure: Originally the tallest.
Lucia: 合影环节
Lucia: Group photo session.
Shure:  然后就还给自己加磅是吗
Shure: Then add weight to yourself, right?
Jake: 哎请坐请坐
Jake: Hey, have a seat, have a seat.
Tasha: 你笨来就最高
Tasha: You were the tallest from the start.
Alice: 坐刘婷
Alice: Sit down, Liu Ting.
Jake: 请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit, please sit.
Alice: 坐
Alice: Sit.
Lucia: 你怎么这么高
Lucia: Why are you so tall?
其他人： 怎么都没人坐啊
Others: Why is no one sitting?
Jake: 请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit, please sit.
Jake: 三位客人请坐
Jake: Three guests, please sit.
Lucia: 前在坐着后面站着怎么像那种家族照一样
Lucia: Sitting in front, standing in the back, looks like a family portrait.
Lucia: 豪门家族照 一样
Lucia: Like a wealthy family's portrait.
Shure:  老板老板老板
Shure: Boss, boss, boss.
Shure:  来来来
Shure: Come, come, come.
Jake: 老板老板老板
Jake: Boss, boss, boss.
Shure:  老板站中间老板站中间
Shure: Boss, stand in the middle, boss, stand in the middle.
Jake: 站后面站旁边就好了
Jake: Stand at the back, standing beside is fine.
Shure: 你也得过来
Shure: You have to come over too.
Lucia:  你这个相机有自动那个什么吗
Lucia: Does this camera have an auto thing?
Jake: 有
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 有三脚架
Jake: It has a tripod.
Shure:  但是没有
Shure: But it doesn't.
Jake: 有三脚架
Jake: It has a tripod.
Jake: 对我们三脚架l多了
Jake: Yes, we have a lot of tripods.
Tasha: 他有刀
Tasha: He has a knife.
Lucia: 哎现在可以
Lucia: Hey, now it works.
Lucia: 哦不可以
Lucia: Oh, it doesn't.
Lucia: 你是没那啥了
Lucia: You're out of luck.
Alice: 我打你吗
Alice: Should I hit you?
Shure:  就等你呢
Shure: We've been waiting for you.
Jake: 对就等你了
Jake: Yeah, just waiting for you.
Shure:  我们算到了其实是
Shure: We actually figured it out.
Alice: 我我我我狗的老老婆呢
Alice: Where's my, my, my old dog wife?
Jake: 在这蹲俩是吧
Jake: Squatting here, right?
Lucia: 还可以让他们加进来可以吗
Lucia: Can we let them join, is that okay?
Jake: 猜不到吧
Jake: Can't guess, right?
Shure:  让他俩他俩也进来
Shure: Let them both come in.
Lucia: 他俩在前面
Lucia: They're in front.
Shure:  他俩在前面
Shure: They're in front.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 这边
Jake: Over here.
Lucia: 要不咱俩换一下那个啥
Lucia: Should we switch that thing?
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 这样可以在
Lucia: This way we can...
其他人： 你想过来就来吧别太矜持了
Others: If you want to come over, just do it, don't be so reserved.
Lucia: 你在这边咱们可以这样
Lucia: You over here, we can do this.
Alice: 我打不着你了是吧
Alice: I can't hit you now, right?
Alice:见证见证一对一对新人
Alice: Witnessing a new couple.
Lucia: 一对新人一对新狗
Lucia: A new couple and a new dog couple.
其他人： 一对新狗的诞生
Others: The birth of a new dog couple.
Lucia: 你的狗戴花花
Lucia: Your dog is wearing flowers.
Shure:  上面那个够pro的给卸一下
Shure: Take off that GoPro.
Lucia: 你的狗才是新娘
Lucia: Your dog is the bride.
Jake:goPro的
Jake: The GoPro one.
Alice: 感谢你特别邀请
Alice: Thank you for the special invitation.
Jake: 然后你看怎么搞的
Jake: Then, see how to handle this.
Tasha: 拍卖结束之后干嘛啊
Tasha: What do we do after the auction?
Jake: 它是有一个
Jake: There's a...
Tasha: 拍卖结束之后干嘛啊
Tasha: What do we do after the auction?
Jake: 行行没问题
Jake: Okay, no problem.
Jake:对上吗
Jake: Does it match?
Lucia: 救命
Lucia: Help!
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 后面没
Jake: Nothing at the back.
Alice: 祸乱后宫罪不容诛
Alice: Creating chaos in the harem is an unforgivable crime.
Jake:是一页吗
Jake: Is it one page?
Shure:  就就放这页吧
Shure: Just put it on this page.
Shure:  那个放白的那个有点就是照到脸上了
Shure: The white one is kind of reflecting on the face.
Jake:OK行行行
Jake: OK, got it.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Lucia: 咱这甚至还有补光灯呢
Lucia: We even have a fill light here.
Lucia: 不虚
Lucia: Not bad.
Alice: 对不起对不起对不起
Alice: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Jake: 补光灯要到前面的
Jake: The fill light should be in the front.
Jake: 还不用啊
Jake: Not needed yet.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 好热啊
Tasha: It's so hot.
Alice: 来吧
Alice: Let's go.
Jake: 雨萱拿
Jake: Yuxuan, take it.
Jake: 可以拿一个眼镜
Jake: You can take a pair of glasses.
Jake: 你可以不戴
Jake: You don't have to wear them.
Jake: 你也可以
Jake: You can too.
其他人： 10秒自拍模式 启动
Others: 10-second selfie mode, start!
Alice: OK
Alice: OK.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay!
Shure:  来吧我觉得这波才艺
Shure: Come on, I think this talent is great.
Jake:很有才艺
Jake: Very talented.
Shure:  123456
Shure: 123456
Jake: 黄一波
Jake: Huang Yibo.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Shure:  6个吧
Shure: Six of them, right?
Shure:  行 再来俩吧
Shure: Alright, let's do two more.
Shure:  8个吧发发发
Shure: Eight of them, let's go!
其他人：凳子把凳子再搬回去呗
Others: Move the chairs back.
其他人： 都是谁对应的凳子再拿回去
Others: Everyone, take back your corresponding chairs.
Alice: Lucia
Alice: Lucia.
Shure:  大家搬搬下凳子
Shure: Everyone, move your chairs.
Shure:  然后回到原位
Shure: Then go back to your positions.
Shure:  然后我们继续进行这个拍卖环节
Shure: Then we'll continue with the auction segment.
Tasha: 还有谁
Tasha: Who else?
Shure:  谢斌竹呢谢斌竹呢
Shure: Xie Binzhu, where is Xie Binzhu?
Shure:  谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu.
Tasha: 点什么呀
Tasha: What are we pointing at?
Jake: 披萨大披萨超级大披萨
Jake: Pizza, big pizza, super big pizza.
Alice: 大庭广众
Alice: In public
Alice: 刘婷你的够花吗
Alice: Liu Ting, do you have enough flowers?
Alice: 要不我给你偷俩
Alice: How about I steal a couple for you?
Alice: 我去偷俩这是假钞吧
Alice: I'll go steal a couple, are these fake bills?
Lucia: 你在check吗
Lucia: Are you checking?
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me see
Tasha: 你买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy it?
Tasha: 那你就想点跑腿
Tasha: Then just think of it as a delivery
Lucia: 不错不错
Lucia: Not bad, not bad
Lucia: 预热这个
Lucia: Warm this up
Lucia: 那个那个灯
Lucia: That light, that one
其他人：修硕
Others: Shure
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah
Shure:  就是那最大最大那个
Shure: It's the biggest one, the biggest one
Shure:  24的话24的话咱们是几个人10个人
Shure: If it's 24, if it's 24, how many are we? 10 people
Lucia:  那我得坚持10秒吗
Lucia: Then do I have to hold for 10 seconds?
Shure:  其实点一个然后再点点别的吧
Shure: Actually, press one and then press some other ones
Lucia: 好久
Lucia: So long
Lucia: 表情都不自然了
Lucia: My expression is getting unnatural
Tasha: 点个榴莲的吧
Tasha: Order a durian one
Alice: Lucia我想跟你合照一张
Alice: Lucia, I want to take a picture with you
Lucia: 好呀
Lucia: Sure
Lucia: 只要有福星出现的地方
Lucia: Wherever there's a lucky star
Lucia: 他就会变成摄影师
Lucia: He'll turn into the photographer
Alice: 真好啊
Alice: That's great
Lucia: sorry sorry sorry my fault
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, sorry, my fault
Lucia: 要不要把它转一下打到脸上
Lucia: Should we turn it to shine on our faces?
Lucia: 我们站这边的话可以调
Lucia: If we stand here, we can adjust it
Alice: 其实可以调一下
Alice: Actually, we can adjust it
Lucia: 让他给脸上补点光之类的
Lucia: Let him add some light to our faces or something
Alice: 那我们站这里
Alice: Then we'll stand here
Alice: 差不多
Alice: Almost there
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay
Alice: 我我我不太会拍哦
Alice: I, I, I'm not good at taking pictures
Alice: 你就说什么
Alice: Just tell me what to do
Lucia: 这这这还是你之前的相机头
Lucia: This, this, this is still your old camera lens
Alice: 这可以打鸟吗
Alice: Can this shoot birds?
Lucia: 哇你怎么带这么奇装备
Lucia: Wow, why did you bring such strange equipment
Shure:  来
Shure: Here
Alice: 我是点这个就可以
Alice: I just press this, right?
Shure:  我们我们
Shure: We we
Shure:  order
Shure: order
Tasha: 还有甜品吗
Tasha: Do you have any dessert?
Tasha: 不要不要不要
Tasha: No, no, no
Tasha: 一次性餐具
Tasha: Disposable utensils
Alice: 这是拍上了吗
Alice: Is this being recorded?
Alice: 是不是有点太近了
Alice: Isn't it a bit too close?
Alice: 好谢谢
Alice: Okay, thanks
Tasha: 不是不是
Tasha: No, no
Shure:  来吧现在我们下一位拍卖者
Shure: Alright, now our next auctioneer
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 店内自取
Tasha: Pick-up in store
其他人：这个呢是一盒可孚 的牙线棒
Others: This is a box of Coflu floss sticks
其他人： 为什么要选择这个呢 主要是因为有一句老话叫什么叫
Others: Why choose this? Mainly because there's an old saying, what does it say...
Alice: 叫啥呀
Alice: What does it say?
Tasha: 他拿了个牙线
Tasha: He picked up floss
其他人： 啊麦斯尔夫说的
Others: Ah, it was said by Mayself
其他人： 说一句是牙齿疼的时候可是要命啊这句话
Others: He said when a tooth aches, it's deadly, that's the saying
其他人： 你确定定话是麦斯尔夫说的
Others: Are you sure Mayself said that?
其他人： 啊对麦斯尔夫说的
Others: Yeah, Mayself said it
其他人：对牙齿健康口腔健康 对我们来额外的重要
Others: Yes, dental health, oral health, is extremely important for us
其他人： 我们从 一个币开始拍
Others: We start the bidding at one coin
其他人： 一个
Others: One
其他人： OK
Others: OK
其他人： 一个币一个币还有吗
Others: One coin, one coin, anyone else?
Jake: 这就是传媒人么
Jake: Is this what media people do?
其他人：5个币是吗
Others: Five coins, right?
其他人：一个币一个币一次
Others: One coin, one coin, once
Shure:  算了算了
Shure: Forget it, forget it
其他人：一个币两次
Others: One coin, twice
Shure:  一个币两次
Shure: One coin, twice
Shure:  主要
Shure: Main
其他人：三个币是吧
Others: Three coins, right?
Alice: 我都没有我跟你讲
Alice: I don't even have any, I'm telling you
其他人： OK一个币三次恭喜你
Others: OK, one coin, three times, congratulations
其他人： 太好了
Others: Great
其他人：内部消化了
Others: Internal consumption
Lucia: 就当是他拍的因为那个小狗没跟我收钱
Lucia: Just consider it bought because that puppy didn't charge me
Tasha: 你知道靖康他
Tasha: You know Jingkang, he
Tasha: 他用美团用美团日付你知道吗
Tasha: He uses Meituan, pays daily, you know?
Shure:  亲兄弟明算账是吧
Shure: Clear accounts between brothers, right?
Alice: 在身无分币的年纪遇见了最想要的啥
Alice: Met what I wanted most when I was penniless.
Tasha: 他把他的美团日付刷爆了
Tasha: He maxed out his Meituan daily limit.
Alice: 牙线棒是吗哈哈哈
Alice: Dental floss sticks, right? Hahaha.
Tasha: 两千
Tasha: Two thousand.
其他人： OKOK接下来 是我们第二个拍品是一本书叫 月亮河6
Others: OK, OK, next up is our second auction item, a book called "Moon River 6".
其他人： 不会是盗版书吧
Others: It won't be a pirated book, right?
Shure:  盗版书
Shure: Pirated book.
其他人：不能吧我看一下
Others: No way, let me check.
Alice: 你从哪偷的你跟我说说
Alice: Where did you steal it from? Tell me.
Lucia:  月亮河6件事
Lucia: "Moon River 6" stuff.
其他人：OKOK就是 有这么一本书啊 俗话说的好
Others: OK, OK, so there's such a book. As the saying goes...
其他人： 这个书籍是人类进步的阶梯 这个应该不是我说的
Others: Books are the ladder of human progress. I didn't say that.
其他人： 那么我们是的是的那
Others: So we are, yes...
Shure:  这是高尔基说的
Shure: That was Gorky.
其他人： 那我们这个第二件拍卖品起步价一个币
Others: Then the starting price for our second auction item is one coin.
Lucia:  一个币
Lucia: One coin.
其他人：一个币一次
Others: One coin, going once.
Shure:  这个绝版了这是
Shure: This is a limited edition.
其他人：这可是月亮河 哈哈哈
Others: This is "Moon River", hahaha.
Shure:  我看看这到底是谁写
Shure: Let me see who wrote this.
其他人： 可能就是译文有问题应该是原版
Others: Maybe it's just the translation that's the issue, should be original.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Is that so?
其他人： 应该是一个看起来很像盗版正版书
Others: It should look like a legitimate pirated book.
其他人：满地都是月亮他却抬头看到6便士
Others: The ground is full of moons, but he looks up and sees sixpence.
Shure:  是那个
Shure: Is that...
Lucia: 你冷静一点
Lucia: Calm down.
其他人： 一个币两次
Others: One coin, going twice.
Shure:  2个币
Shure: Two coins.
其他人：OK两个币一次
Others: OK, two coins, going once.
其他人： 这么胜券再握书都拿走了
Others: So confident, already won the book.
Shure:  没有了
Shure: That's it.
其他人：两个币两次哦
Others: Two coins, going twice.
Shure:  谢斌竹出3个币
Shure: Xie Binzhu offers three coins.
其他人：什么什么
Others: What, what?
Tasha: 他出3个币嗯
Tasha: He offers three coins.
其他人： OK三个币 一次
Others: OK, three coins, going once.
其他人：这个错版书错版书三个币两次
Others: This misprinted book, three coins, going twice.
其他人：OK三个币三次成交
Others: OK, three coins, going thrice, sold!
其他人：谢云竹拿钱
Others: Xie Yunzhu, pay up.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人： 哈银行突然多了3块钱的
Others: Haha, the bank suddenly has 3 more bucks
Tasha: 突然负债三个币
Tasha: Suddenly in debt by three coins
其他人：我想说为什么说它错版
Others: I was wondering why they said it was a misprint
Shure:  因为月亮和六便士啊
Shure: Because of "The Moon and Sixpence"
Shure:  谢斌竹觉得还挺对的哈哈哈
Shure: Xie Binzhu thinks it's quite right, haha
其他人： 月亮与六便士那么翻译问题吗我操
Others: "The Moon and Sixpence", is it a translation issue? Damn
Lucia: 应该是重大
Lucia: It should be important
Shure:  来吧来吧 3个币
Shure: Come on, come on, 3 coins
Lucia:  从公家出啊
Lucia: From public funds, huh
Shure:  啊他给的是吧
Shure: Ah, he gave it, right?
Shure:  我以为他
Shure: I thought he
Alice: 别说出来
Alice: Don't say it out loud
Alice: 你这不偷偷拿6个
Alice: Didn't you secretly take 6
Alice: 你给我
Alice: Give it to me
Shure:  他从世界银行走的我以为
Shure: He got it from the World Bank, I thought
Lucia: 怒赚六个
Lucia: Earned six angrily
Shure:  好的
Shure: Alright
Shure:  那我们下一位
Shure: Then let's move on to the next one
Shure:  没了晚上啊
Shure: That's all for tonight
Shure:  还有还有
Shure: There's more, there's more
Tasha: 你不想打电话是吧
Tasha: You don't want to make the call, right?
Shure:  小杜
Shure: Xiao Du
其他人： 我从学校带来一钥匙链 行胜一言钥匙链
Others: I brought a keychain from school, a keychain with a saying
其他人：好我就要拍了
Others: Okay, I'm going to take a photo
Tasha: 什么东西啊
Tasha: What is it?
其他人：这个相当 我这个跟了我半年里面积攒了我所有写代码的怨恨
Others: This is quite something, it's been with me for half a year, accumulating all my coding grievances
其他人： 那个我大脑骂人的 语气我下班回家的开心还有那 在学校里面
Others: My brain cursing, my happiness after work, and that, in school
其他人： 怨灵
Others: Grudge spirit
Shure:  精华
Shure: Essence
Shure:  一个两个三个四个
Shure: One, two, three, four
Lucia: 开过光的开过光的
Lucia: Blessed, blessed
其他人：你要再再再
Others: Do you want more, more, more
其他人：一个是清华校徽
Others: One is the Tsinghua emblem
其他人：这边有清华大学
Others: This one says Tsinghua University
其他人：一个是二少儿
Others: One is the Second Children's
其他人： 然后一个是那个
Others: And then there's that
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Come on
Shure:  那么我们现在开始
Shure: So, let's start now
Shure:  一个币的起拍
Shure: Starting bid is one coin.
Shure:  一个
Shure: One.
Shure:  L同学出一个
Shure: L bids one.
Shure:  一个币一次
Shure: One coin, once.
Tasha: 我让他5分钟后到店
Tasha: I'll have him come to the shop in 5 minutes.
Tasha: 大概多长时间做好
Tasha: How long will it take to finish?
Shure:  LL同学出了两个
Shure: LL bids two.
Shure:  2个币一次
Shure: Two coins, once.
Shure:  两个币两次
Shure: Two coins, twice.
Alice: 怨恨这么大的东西才两个币
Alice: Only two coins for something this big?
其他人：这店里挺贵的呢
Others: This shop is quite expensive.
Lucia:  3 个
Lucia: Three.
Shure:  3个
Shure: Three.
Shure:  3个币一次
Shure: Three coins, once.
Shure:  主办有没有想想想想要的
Shure: Does the host have any other thoughts?
Shure:  3个币的啊
Shure: Three coins?
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Alice: 给我掏钱吗
Alice: Are you going to pay for me?
Lucia: 掏过了我的存款
Lucia: I've already used up my savings.
Shure:  3个币一次
Shure: Three coins, once.
Shure:  3个币两次
Shure: Three coins, twice.
Alice: 我可以带4个币吗
Alice: Can I bid four coins?
Shure:  我我出4个
Shure: I'll bid four.
Shure:  4个币一次
Shure: Four coins, once.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Shure:  什么4个币两次了
Shure: What? Four coins, twice.
Alice: 老公给我买
Alice: My husband will buy it for me.
Alice: 我我出的四个呀
Alice: I bid four.
Shure:  5个币一次
Shure: Five coins, once.
Alice: 4是我出的呀
Alice: I bid four!
Alice: 你压我干啥
Alice: Why are you outbidding me?
Shure:  5个币两次
Shure: Five coins, twice.
Shure:  5个币三次
Shure: Five coins, three times.
Alice: 我没有
Alice: I don’t have it.
Tasha: 算了吧小程序点吧
Tasha: Forget it, just use the app.
Alice: 我不都贷款吗
Alice: I’ll just take a loan.
Shure:  成交
Shure: Sold.
Tasha: 你就问他你就跟你就把那个码报给他
Tasha: Just tell him the code.
Tasha: 你就把这个码报给他
Tasha: Just give him the code.
Tasha: 然后你说大概多长时间做好就行
Tasha: And tell him how long it will take to finish.
其他人：没事儿你从我这10个币买走
Others: No worries, you can buy it from me for 10 coins.
Shure:  哈哈哈人家就是那学校的
Shure: Hahaha, he’s from that school.
Lucia: 二道贩子
Lucia: Middleman.
Shure:  还有还有auction
Shure: Also, also, auction.
Shure:  什么any auction anymore
Shure: Any auction anymore?
Tasha: 不卖了不卖了
Tasha: Not selling, not selling.
Jake: 不卖了不卖了
Jake: Not selling, not selling.
Jake: 卖卖卖卖卖一部卖一部
Jake: Sell, sell, sell, sell, sell one.
Shure:  哦哦
Shure: Oh, oh.
Shure:  大家可以看到
Shure: Everyone can see.
Tasha: 您来您来
Tasha: Come on, come on.
Shure:  我们的大厨上来吧
Shure: Let's welcome our chef.
Shure:  来来我们的我们的
Shure: Come on, our, our.
Shure:  甜点甜点king
Shure: Dessert, dessert king.
Shure:  desert king还是desert king来着
Shure: Desert king or dessert king?
其他人： 我还要找骑手干嘛 呀
Others: Why do I still need a rider?
Shure:  desert还是desert desert吧
Shure: Desert or dessert, let's go with dessert.
其他人：啊这是拍
Others: Ah, this is shooting.
其他人： 是呀
Others: Yes.
其他人：刚才都
Others: Just now…